un mari l'explosif au fait ce sont des
armes donc ils sont produites localement
syrie se sont littéralement des barils
de formes différentes dans les clans
remettre des livres pour tirer un
maximum de dégâts quand ils vont
atterrir
ils font jeter d'hélicoptères souvent
des de l'arrière de l'hélicoptère est le
problème avec ses bars il sait que ils
sont souvent jetée de très très haute
altitude parce que l'hélicoptère venu
pour éviter toute forme d'attaqué sur
elle et ce sont des armes qui ne peuvent
pas être dirigés donc une focale sont
jetés ne discrimine pas entre un
objectif militaire où un objectif lille
donc ils finissent souvent par tuer des
civils et par détruire l'infrastructure
essentielle dans les villes et les
villages sont à déterminer qui a eu par
exemple alerte durant l'année c'est plus
de 1000 au bond au baril exclusifs et à
d'autres types d'attaqués aériennes et
alors que sud du pays dont dix villages
et petites villes du sud de la série on
a pu distinguer 450 cratère qui sont
conformes aux dégâts causés par des
barils explosifs
on sait que seul le régime à contrôler à
une forte de l'air donc on sait que tous
les explosifs qui sont jetés sont des
explosifs jeté par l'armée de bachar al
assad
les rebelles n'ont pas de capacités
aériennes et le net résultat c'est que
ce sont des attaques indiscriminées sont
des attaques que le conseil de sécurité
incluant la russie la chine il ya un an
ont demandé au gouvernement de bachar al
assad d'arrêter de commettre d'attac
pareil est malheureusement un an après
il ya eu aucune mesure qu'il a été pris
tous les jours il ya des témoins qui
voit ses hélicoptères qui lâchent les
bombes nous mêmes quand on allait encore
à alep sonore de la série on a été
témoin direct de ces bombes qui tombent
on entend l'hélicoptère on le voit au
ciel et puis soudainement on voit le
baril qui tombe il ya des vidéos prises
de l'intérieur de certains hélicoptères
on voit les barriques qui sont jetés
c'est cette amérique de nier cela devant
tous les faits qui sont très claires et
babar ils sont tombés sur le quartier
résidentiel dans certains cas y sont
tombés sur des hôpitaux sur des écoles
nous mêmes on n'a pas de de l'ifpi non
exhaustif mais nous savons que le prix
et surtout payés mal
clairement par les civils et que c'est
pas simplement en train de tuer et
blesser les filles en train de pousser
un grand mouvement de réfugiés
des villes comme à l'aide et du sud du
pays par peur de ces barils finalement
aujourd'hui on n'en parle plus tellement
parce que c'est l'état islamique qui
commet toute l'attention internationale
mais faut savoir que la majorité des
civils qui me rend fier aujourd'hui sont
toujours des gens qui sont morts bien
aux mains du gouvernement ou bien
d'autres groupes rebelles
il faut que qu'on reparle de la justice
pour les victimes en syrie et en
demandant qu'on fait de sécurité de
référé la situation à la cour pénale
internationale